mesdames messieurs chers collègues nous
allons donc débuter notre audition je
voudrais vous indiquez préalablement que
convient de respecter les distances
naturellement que nous connaissons bien
maintenant mais vous diront aussi que
l'audition de monsieur le ministre est
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du sénat
il ya également des collègues qui nous
suivent mais je vois sur richard en
photo en visioconférence naturellement
chacun pour intervenir l'audition de ce
soir porte naturellement principalement
sur le texte que nous avons à connaître
ceux intitulés sécurité globale
naturellement d'autres questions
pourraient arriver et peut-être une en
particulier qui nous a interrogés à la
commission des lois ou de décence je
cherche du regard
madame mais c'est dur à de la gontrie
relative monsieur le ministre a au point
des trois d eau d sur les trois décrets
qui ont été pris le 2 décembre dernier
qui ont modifié les dispositions du code
de la sécurité intérieure relatives en
particulier au traitement des données à
caractère personnel et qui permettent de
recueillir des données relatives à
l'appartenance syndicale aux activités
politiques aux convictions
philosophiques et religieuses mais
également les identifiants sur les
réseaux sociaux et certaines données de
santé ceci parce que cela s'avère
nécessaire en matière de sécurité
publique ou de sûreté de l'état pour
conseil d'état en référé a estimé qu
aucun des arguments avancés par les
requérants qui avait fait un recours
ils étaient de nature à faire naître un
doute sérieux sur la légalité de ces
dispositions qu'en fait le fait
d'attester que des opinions puissent
représenter un danger en elle-même
démontrent d'une rupture dans la manière
de penser la sûreté de l'état pour la
difficulté particulière n'existe pas
tout de même un risque c'est de me
disent on aimerait vous entendre
sur ce point et puis ma deuxième
question et moi ensuite je me tairai au
profit de vous même des collègues nous
abordons le texte sécurité globale et au
même moment sont annoncés à la pause
avait annoncé le bobo de la sécurité
d'une part et d'autre part engagé un
débat sur la réforme entre la police et
la gendarmerie nous inscrivons dans cet
ensemble là nous voudrions y voir clair
sur la manière dont les choses vont
s'organiser et il n'y a t'il pas où il
ya tu peux être une difficulté à aborder
ce texte aujourd'hui intitulé sécurité
globale et en même temps avoir d'autres
démarches et les complémentarités auquel
cas c'est des complémentarités
nous souhaitons pouvoir en être j'ai vu
expliqué je ne sais pas moi j'en ai
terminé monsieur le ministre je vous
laisse naturellement la parole tout de
suite passé le président vous souhaitez
que nous abordions deux temps la
commission d'abord les fichiers ensuite
sécurité globale où ça permettrait de
régler le problème tout de suite
peut-être en prend en matière de
désorganisation de nos débats c'est
peut-être là bord les fichiers bien
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs permettez moi
tout d'abord de vous adresser mes voeux
les plus sincères de bonheur de santé et
de réussite bien sûr dans vos mandats et
dans vos vies personnelles sur la
question des fichiers que vous avez
évoqué j'avais répondu monsieur le
président à une question au sénat avant
la trêve des confiseurs et c'est bien
évidemment avec bonheur que je veux bien
repréciser les choses surtout que vous
l'avez dit vous-même le conseil d'état a
jugé entre temps des dispositions
conformes sur le référé et renvoyant au
fond à sa drôle de sujet même si déjà le
conseil d'état a jugé en partie au fonds
dans ses pensées référé ces fichiers que
vous évoquez ont été créés entre 2009 et
ils ont été codifiées dans le code de la
sécurité intérieure vous l'avez dit des
trois décrets que vous avez évoquées ont
été publiés le 2 décembre 2020 notamment
suite à un contrôle de la cnil en 2017
et 2018 qui a donc engagé en partie
les modifications que j'ai eue a publié
par ce décret du 2 décembre
il s'agit de deux types de fichiers
différents le premier ce qu'on appelle
le asp l'enquète administratives via la
sécurité publique qui relèvent de la
direction générale de la police
nationale et de la préfecture de police
de paris
ce sont des informations nécessaires qui
sont criblés à chaque fois c'est fait
sous le cadre d' enquête donc attribué
par les renseignements territoriaux qui
permettent à l'issue de ces enquêtes de
pouvoir tenir un fichier qui a
actuellement quand je vis actuellement
c'est le mois de novembre
221 1711 en l'occurrence dans ce dans ce
fichier pour pouvoir mettre en place ce
fichier qui permet de lister les
personnes qui ont vocation à accéder à
des bâtiments ou des sites sensibles
pour l'état dans l'exercice de la
souveraineté de fonctions de préfet ou
d'ambassadeur par exemple ont des
fonctions particulièrement évidemment
exposés ou parfois pour des ordres
nationaux il s'agit donc de mettre dans
ce fichier pour la suite des enquêtes
crible par les rt des dispositions qui
permettent de voir si les personnes sont
ou ne sont pas dignes de pouvoir accéder
à ces sujets de sûreté d'état de
souveraineté les deuxièmes deuxième type
de fichier c'est le psp et de jp asp le
ps paie parce que c'est la prévention
des atteintes à la sécurité publique
le fichier de la direction générale de
la police nationale enrichie par le
français bataillent taurian est la drpp
la direction des renseignements de la
préfecture de police de paris et le gie
psp qui à peu près sont parallèles pour
la dggn la direction générale la
gendarmerie nationale tous les deux à
peu près 60 mille ou 60 7000 selon l'un
ou l'autre de nom d'ailleurs ce n'est
pas cumulable il ya souvent des
occurrences dans les deux un côté
gendarmerie d'à côté police qui fait que
ce n'est pas s'en va mais non en tout
évidemment comme ces fichiers ne sont
pas fusionner ce qui est une garantie
des libertés publiques des personnes
doivent se retrouver dans les deux
fichiers ces deux fichiers sont
légèrement différent du premier que j'ai
évoquées il s'agit de la conservation
des des identités des individus dont
l'activité peut porter atteinte à la
sûreté de l'état qui peut intéresser
l'ordre public ou être en lien avec des
fans de violence collective et donc ses
fichiers
obtenue par les services de police et
gendarmerie que j'évoquais alors ces
fichiers se présentent comme des fiches
individuelles avec des fiches annexe est
d'ailleurs en pdf qui permet évidemment
de pouvoir ne pas faire de recherche
soit sur la photo soit sur d'autres
dispositions qui sont expressément
prévus par le par le décret est long et
c'est bien naturel étaient contrôlés par
la cnil par le conseil d'état il ya eu
également une analyse d'impact de
protection des données telles que
prévoit la loi et par ailleurs ils ont
été publiés contrairement à beaucoup de
fichiers de souveraineté ce qui garantit
je crois l'information normal des
citoyens et bien évidemment des
parlementaires qui évoque ce sujet
aujourd'hui je voudrais souligner que
pour trois raisons je terminerais là
monsieur le président tout en répondant
évidemment à toutes les questions que
vous souhaiterez d'abord que se fichent
ces fichiers ont été modifiés n'ont pas
créé à la demande de la cnil elle même
suite à ces contrôles de 2017 et 2018 ce
qu'elle a réaffirmé dans ses communiqués
de presse qui sont évidemment votre
disposition comme dans ses arrêts nous
avons repris puisque c'était le moment
de les modifier les dispositions de la
loi hergé puisque les fichiers
avaient été créées avant la loi rg pda
profondeur par votre haute assemblée
dans les dispositions que nous évoquons
notamment sur la question de l'activité
ou de l'opinion c'était une question qui
avait été posé leurs gpd la transmission
telle qu'elle était faite par les
instances européennes vote par le
parlement le texte de loi informatique
et libertés prévoit opinion politique et
une part active ite et c'est la cnil
elle même qui nous a demandé de modifier
cette occurrence
et puis enfin nous y avons rajouté des
catégories sur les activités sur les
réseaux sociaux
évidemment puisque en 2009 et 2011 il
n'y avait pas une telle un tel lien
entre les activités subversives les
atteintes à la sûreté de l'état et des
activités évidemment répéter sur les
réseaux sociaux qui peuvent intéresser
des services de renseignement les
services de police et de gendarmerie
voilà en quelques mots monsieur le
président vous avez effectivement évoqué
le fait que suit pourtant à des avis
conforme de la cnil pourtant à
désapprouve des approbations du conseil
d'état ces décrets ont été attaqués et
que le conseil d'état dans une
t'es sûr toute récente a donné raison au
ministère de l'intérieur merci aussi mis
sur ce point j'ai deux questions
monsieur du rhin qui se pose une
question et ensuite madame monsieur
durand merci monsieur le président va
d'abord vous remercier d'avoir relayé
ces demandes que notre groupe avait
présenté au sujet des fichiers cette
demande de précisions auprès du ministre
que nous saluons et que nous remercions
pour ses voeux vous adresse ce ministre
aussi des voeux d'une année apaisé et
dans cette affaire de fichiers il est
autant question de l'égalité d'ailleurs
que de climat alors la question de
l'égalité
c'est évidemment l'élargissement de la
liste des informations collectées
l'élargissement du type de personnes
concernées on avait des personnes
physiques on a maintenant des personnes
morales l'élargissement de ce qu'ils
peuvent consulter ces fichiers alors
sans emphase ni excès certains évoquent
les lois scélérates ce que vous êtes une
personnalité d'une grande culture donc
on va pas les chercher dans l'histoire
ancienne des choses trop trop excessive
mais il ya un vrai questionnement de
personnalités publiques de juristes qui
trouve quand même qu'on pousse un peu
loin la collecte d'informations
d'informations qui vont d'ailleurs des
finalités et des sensibilités de nature
très différente
ce qui nous inquiète et un des objets de
ma question c'est de savoir si on vient
par ces décrets finalement régulariser
comme je les lui des pratiques étaient
déjà en cours sans base juridique savoir
comment les fonctionnaires qui auront à
renseigner ses fichiers se conformer
parce que quand il s'agit d'apprécier
des options philosophiques politiques
il faut quand même avoir un peu de
discernement et de subtilité voilà pour
les aspects l'égalité et puis est ce que
ça ne vient quand même pas dans un
contexte où chacun peut observer qui a
une grande tension dans notre pays une
grande inquiétude des désordres
psychologiques individuels et collectifs
jeter un peu d'huile sur le feu
les questions de sécurité publique sont
extrêmement sensibles on a un autre
texte qui arrive et qui suscite bien des
émotions
j'ai lu un texte d'un une missive d'un
député de guyane qui s'étonnaient du
recours aux chiens pour réprimer une
manifestation hier à cayenne on a un peu
partout sur le territoire des éléments
d'inquiétude
ils sont très épars mais qui contribuent
un désordre dans le climat du pays je
pense dans la région bourgogne franche
comté à un boulanger là qu'ils se
mobilisent par une grève de la faim
stéphane raclée pour un jeune guinéen
qui va être expulsé voilà tous ces
ferments d'inquiétude
au delà des fichiers de palaces de
nature à entretenir un climat qui n'est
pas sain qui contrevient aux libertés du
public en tout cas le sentiment qu'on en
a et donc du coup j'aimerais que vous
puissiez nous éclairer sur les quelques
questions que vous est posée
merci monsieur du rhin madame benbassa
merci monsieur le président d'abord tous
mes voeux pour à tout le monde que cette
année soit plus sereine est-ce que ce
soit l'année de la santé retrouvée alors
ma première question se rassure je
suçais se fichent ces fichiers
je me pose la question de savoir
pourquoi étendre ce fichier aux opinions
politiques convictions philosophiques
religieuses mais aussi à l'appartenance
syndicale
et en quoi ce fichage permettrait de
lutter plus efficacement contre la
menace terroriste
et deuxièmement et en quoi je vous
demande quelques précisions en surtout
sur la mention d' atteinte aux
institutions de la république et
dernière question
selon les dispositions de cd clé les
personnes morales en l'occurrence les
associations pourront désormais
également faire l'objet de ces mesures
quelles garanties
le gouvernement entend t-il mettre en
place pour protéger la liberté
d'association et la liberté d'opinion au
sein de ces associations françaises
voilà merci merci madame à notre
question monsieur le ministre vous
pousse de de répondre ensuite nous
aborderons le texte sécurité globale
merci monsieur président peut-être très
rapidement d'abord je ne peux pas
laisser dire si monsieur c'est à temps
le permet qui contrevient aux libertés
publiques voilà un texte qui a été
validé d'abord validé par le conseil
d'état et par la cnil en amont et validé
par le conseil d'état en aval donc je
pense que le conseil d'état est le
garant de nos libertés publiques a
souligné à quel point les textes étaient
respectueux d'autant plus respectueux
qui ont été faits à la demande de la
cnil
mm évidemment et c'est un point
important
ensuite vous évoquez peut-être que c'est
la même question mais massa sur la
question des opinions je répète encore
une fois que ce n'était pas fait la
demande du gouvernement que c'est le
législateur lui-même qui a inscrit
opinions politiques plutôt qu activités
politiques et que vous l'avez voter en
tant que haute assemblée d'ailleurs dans
la loi rgp des la transposition et c'est
l'inscription de la loi informatique et
libertés telle qu'elle a été rédigée par
le législateur et je crois que l'on ne
peut pas reprocher au gouvernement de
vouloir faire paralyse le déforme et
d'inscrire ce que les jette en lui même
a voulu inscrire dans le décret sus
nommé
oui bien sûr les agents sont formés
alors ils sont déjà formés ces fichiers
je le rappelle il existe s'il y avait
d'ailleurs une difficulté de ces
fichiers c'est pas qu'ils étaient
liberticide ces cocons ce qu'au
contraire ils étaient très sommaires
dans leur rédaction et dans les
informations qui ont été données et
c'est même la base du reproche que la
cnil à fin 2017 gouvernement de la
république en expliquant que les
informations données notamment les
catégories de données qui avait été mis
en place par les décrets précédents
étaient rédigées de façon trop sommaire
et pouvaient donner lieu à des
interprétations divergentes sur
paramètres qu'elle recouvrait je cite
ainsi le
la cnil est de son avis est donc ce que
nous avons fait c'est précisé d'ailleurs
à la demande de la cnil en correction
avec sa demande des catégories qui était
moins sommaire beaucoup plus précise et
qui permettait de bien voir quels
étaient les périmètres qu on recouvrait
et donc je crois que si on évoquait ce
travail que la qualifier de
régularisation des pratiques des
services sur la question de la façon
dont fonctionnent les agents ce fichier
à une double qualité si j'ose dire pour
rentrer des informations d'abord l'agent
qui bien sûr est fort mais il travaille
dans un service de renseignement et et
ils sont l'oeuvre d'un grand
professionnalisme
il rentre des éléments et puis les
valider par le par le service central
donc une sorte de double entrée qui
permet de qualifier
l'inscription de ces données bien
évidemment sur le contexte vous je vous
mélanger un peu un peu tout monsieur le
sénateur si je puis me permettre
vous évoquez la difficulté du contexte
moi je verrais le contexte terroristes
qui est touché notre pays
car à côté est extrêmement important
depuis je suis mise intérieure j'ai eu à
connaître plus d'attentats dans un temps
réduit
depuis le gouvernement de monsieur de
monsieur valls
ça fait plus de cinq ans évidemment des
difficultés extrêmement forte pour la
sécurité publique de nos concitoyens
mais aussi des actions subversives qui
ne voient pas les images notamment des
black blocs sur les manifestations dont
chacun se demande comment on arrive pas
à intervenir peut-être que les services
de renseignements n'ont pas forcément
toujours les moyens de le faire en tout
cas ces décrets viennent lutter contre
ceux qui atteinte à la sûreté de l'état
aux institutions je le rappelle
d'ailleurs pour lui ce qui est des
institutions pour madame benbassa il
s'agit notamment du premier des fichiers
celui qui permet justement de cribles et
tous ceux qui ont un
un laissez passer ensuite si j'ose dire
pour aller dans les sites dans les
bâtiments qui sont ceux de sûreté de
l'état ou quand on nomme des préfets ou
des ambassadeurs ou des directeurs
d'administration centrale où des chefs
de service qui sont notamment dans des
services de renseignement il apparaît
normal que la république que puisse
criblé et inscrire la la la la la la
personnalité de ces personnes pour les
rendre évidemment compatible avec les
fonctions éminentes qu'ils vont qu'ils
vont évidemment faire au nom de la
république sur la question des
appartenances syndicales
il ne s'agit pas de ficher les personnes
parce qu'ils ont une opinion religieuse
ou une opinion syndicales ou une opinion
politique
il s'agit par ce qu'ils ont fait des
actions violentes de voir quelles sont
par ailleurs leurs liens si nous parlons
de quelqu'un qui est par exemple dans la
radicalisation islamiste il apparaît
intéressant de savoir qu'il est délégué
syndical peut-être dans une entreprise
peut-être que ça peut aider à certains
de prévenance dans son action et encore
une fois ces renseignements ne sont pas
en soi évidemment des culpabilités mais
permettent je rappelle les chiffres
extrêmement peu nombreux les personnes
concernées 60000 nous permettent
effectivement de pouvoir avoir plus
d'informations sur telle ou telle
personne telle ou telle activité
il s'agit là du niveau bas du
renseignement le niveau et le fichier fs
prt comme comme vous le savez et vient
ainsi compléter le travail que peut
faire les services de renseignements
vous affichez dont je rappelle une fois
qu'il est publié
évidemment contrairement à d'autres
fichiers de de souveraineté donc là il
ne s'agit pas encore une fois j'aurais
bien le répéter de ficher les gens par
opinions politiques par opinion syndical
par opinions religieuses mais parce
qu'ils ont fait des actions violentes ou
parce qu'ils sont suspectés l'excellente
de voir quelle serait évidemment leur
cercle lors cercle d'action
il faut relativiser c'est ce nombre de
personnes le tage fichiers bien connu
ces dix neuf millions de personnes
là il s'agit de fichiers à 60 milles à
peu près personne encore une fois dirigé
directement par les services de
renseignement merci au service je vous
propose qu'on aborde désormais les
textes sécurité globale je vous redonne
la parole bien sûr mais ensuite le
rapporteur mais celui qui avait monsieur
marc philippe daubresse vous poseront
des questions et puis collègues qui le
souhaitent le ferons savoir
et comme habituellement la parole sera
donnée à chacun le sait le ministre bien
monsieur président peut-être en avant
l'introduction rapide sur le texte
sécurité globale en saluant la haute
assemblée pour son travail passé déjà
les nombreuses auditions faites par les
rapporteurs que je salue mais aussi
futurs peut-être en réponse en quelques
instants de vos interpellations sur le
bouvau de la sécurité et sur la question
de la gendarmerie la police nationale et
sa répartition je sais qui intéresse les
parlementaires et singulièrement la
haute assemblée qui qui représente les
collectivités locales à la demande du
président de la république j'ai mis en
place et je lui ai proposé ainsi qu'au
premier ministre
un travail qui permettra de construire
la grande loi de sécurité intérieure que
le prochain gouvernement s'ils le
souhaitent reprendre à son compte ou
modifiera ci n'a envie de le modifier
sur le travail que nous pouvons faire
plus que depuis l'arrivée de la
gendarmerie nationale au ministère de
l'intérieur
il est commun de constater que le
ministère de l'intérieur n'a pas
réfléchi au point de poser notre
sécurité intérieure commune
lp/m pour les armées pour orienter la
sécurité de demain et les services de
sécurité de demain qui concerne autant
la police que la gendarmerie
j'ai donc proposé aux organisations
syndicales de la police qui l'ont toutes
accepté je les en remercie aux
représentants des gendarmes puisqu'ils
ont aussi une nomination qui n'est pas
syndicales mais représentatifs de la
gendarmerie nationale j'ai proposé le
monsieur le président au président
larcher ce matin au président ferrand
pour l'assemblée que des parlementaires
soit désigné également participé à ces
travaux
ainsi qu'à monsieur président des maires
de france de désigner des élus des
maires pour participer à ces travaux
d'avoir cette les syndicats ont demandé
une huitième huit réunions qu'il reprend
mes propos de la commission des lois sur
la formation sur les inspections sur le
maintien de l'ordre
bref sur les sujets qui intéressent
évidemment le ministère de l'intérieur
et la société française pour pouvoir
travailler on va dire tous les quinze
jours je proposais de le faire hein
chaque fois une matinée d'abord prendre
un éclairage international c'est
toujours bien de savoir comment les
autres ont fait comparaison de police
gendarmerie des grands témoins en y
invitant madame la défenseur des droits
des avocats des les anciens policiers
des personnes qui peuvent d'une manière
odieuse re éclairer le débat sur la
sécurité intérieure est évidemment des
propositions formulées pour chacun des
thèmes que nous avons évoquées qui ont
parfois fait florès dans l'opinion
publique
parallèlement j'ai proposé que chaque
semaine dans tous les territoires de la
république je puisse faire avec mes
collègues lorsque ça les intérêts sera
directement avec vous si vous le
souhaitez des débats publics avec les
policiers les gendarmes qu'il faut
savoir écouter mais aussi le monde on à
dire de la société civile et qu'il
faudra voir comment on peut répondre
plus grandes problématiques du monde
rural et notamment des questions
agricoles et sont de plus en plus
attaqués par un certain nombre de
manifestations anti agricoles et comment
la sécurité peut être au rendez vous de
leur demande c'est le cas évidemment des
locaux c'est qu'évidemment de la
jeunesse de france et des entreprises
bref nous pourrions multiplier ces
débats et pour que mois de mai le
président de la république puisse
conclure s'il le souhaitait ce beauvau
de la sécurité créant ainsi les
conditions la rédaction de la loi de
sécurité intérieure que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure il y a eu de mon prédécesseur
une commande de ce président qui était
celui du livre blanc de la sécurité
intérieure qui concernait pas que ceux
de la sécurité en tant que sécurité
force de l'orne si la sécurité civile la
façon dont ils imaginent et évidemment
les grandes crises du ministère de
l'intérieur la façon dont le mini
sanader fonctionné et qui n'est pas que
le ministère de la police ou la
gendarmerie
et parmi les propositions du livre blanc
qui sont soumis à la concertation qui ne
sont que des propositions il ya
effectivement des nouvelles répartitions
qui n'ont jamais été imaginé jusqu'à
leur propre une raison très complexe que
chacun comprend qu'ils essaient de la
répartition territoriale entre la police
et la gendarmerie entre les conurbation
les lieux de transport les territoires
de délinquance qui ont évidemment bouger
parce que les métropoles se sont
agrandies parce que les territoires ont
changé parce que peut-être que la
surface départementale n'est plus tout à
fait celles qui essaient de nos
concitoyens désormais vie l'augmentation
de population dans certaines de certains
territoires et donc ses propositions de
nouvelles cartes je les dis ne sont pas
n'ont pas été faites
par le ministre de l'intérieur lui-même
il va les étudier comme la répartition
des compétences ou même la mutualisation
tout en gardant nos deux forces
gendarmerie et police évidemment séparés
et complémentaire de pouvoir sur le
cyber sur la drogue sur les cambriolages
on pourrait imaginer sur le les aux
grands enjeux de demain
mutualiser assad nombre d'actions et
donc jeudi devant la haute assemblée que
si ces propositions ont été faites
ils sont dans le débat public et que en
2021 nul car tu ne changeras
territoriales mais que j'entreprendrai
évidemment talent étant partir et voir
une discussion avec les forces en
regardant les fait de la vacance avec
les élus pour voir comment nous pouvons
améliorer l'action publique tant au sein
du ministère de l'intérieur
ainsi étant dit monsieur le président
peut être quelques mots soleure la
proposition de loi
communément appelée sécurité globale en
étant heureux de pouvoir faire écho
travail très important qu'on fait des
députés monsieur fauvergue et madame
tour au à l'assemblée nationale dont je
le rappelle qu' il est un des textes les
mieux notés de la législature à
l'assemblée nationale 3 188 voix pour
sur 577 députés comme chacun sait peu de
textes peuvent se résoudre à une telle
majorité englobant très largement
l'hémicycle avec quelques positions il
est vrai de bien solide que prévoit ce
texte très ambitieux avec les avancées
considérables dans trois domaines les
compétences de la police municipale la
sécurité privée et l'utilisation des
images
il prévoit et c'est l'idée principale un
continuum
partant du principe que si l'état est le
responsable et doit rester le
responsable j'y reviendrai de la
sécurité publique
tout le monde participe à la sécurité et
les agents de sécurité privée dont je
rappelle qu'ils ont parfois le payer un
lourd tribut dans la sécurité de nos
concitoyens
nous avons fêté il n'y a malheureusement
pas quelques temps l homo fêter est mal
utilisé bien sûr cet agent de sécurité
qui courageusement empêcher un attentat
au sein du stade de france en empêchant
le théorise de rentrer dans le stade de
france dans les attentats que la france
a connu évidemment on n'aurait pas les
plus compliqués il ya cinq ans les
polices municipales on tourne à vue à
nice qui même sur les questions de
terrorisme intervenez parfois en prime
aux intervenants dans des conditions
extrêmement courageuse et pouvait
d'ailleurs même si ce n'était pas sa
mission première stopper des délinquants
les plus les plus importants puisque
s'agit là d'actes acte terroriste et
chacun sait pour être élu local
l'importance de la police municipale
pour nos concitoyens
évidemment les images qu'il s'agisse des
caméras piétons j'y reviendrai qu'il
s'agisse des drones sûr et qu'il
s'agisse des caméras de vidéo protection
doivent être réglementées d'ailleurs la
cnil nous ils encouragent fortement
mais si la place de l'état et celle
évidemment de la sécurité et qu'elle
doit rester celle de la sécurité il
convient de d'imaginer que nous devons
mieux travailler que nos partenaires
sans les considérer comme des
partenaires de seconde zone trop souvent
les polices municipales ayant été mer
gelée souvent regretté et considéré par
l'état comme une force d'appoint qui on
donne pas beaucoup de renseignements et
à qui on l'espère quelques menues
décision alors que leur rôle et leur
action avec le co construction du maire
le responsable évidemment de ce qui se
passe dans sa commune est tout à fait
tout à fait importante donc nous prenons
au sérieux la sécurité privée
nous traitons dignement les compétences
de police municipale avec une
expérimentation tout à fait originale à
l'article 1er on y reviendra
et nous renforçons la place de l'état je
le dis parce que ce texte ne prévoit
aucun des engagements sur aucun des
acteurs il n'y a pas dans le texte que
nous vous présentons de ce président de
compétence donnée à la police municipale
à la place de la police municipale
nationale
il ya des compétences donné à la police
municipale en même temps que la police
nationale en prenant unis clair
peut-être que ce sera une différence
avec le sénat en tout cas avec sa
majorité
oui pour le constat des délits oui pour
des compétences judiciaires fait unique
et fait nouveau mais non à des actes d'
enquête afin que la police nationale
puisse être toujours responsable de ses
actes d' enquête il s'agit pas de créer
un fbi à et d'un côté et une police
locale de l'autre il s'agit bien
évidemment de garder la spécificité
française mais de permettre que des
choses de bon sens puisse être constatée
par la police municipale qui sera
évidemment gage de meilleure action pour
la sécurité de nos concitoyens
donc ces trois idées forces la réponse
aux élus des différentes demandes et je
remercie les nombreux maires le
président de la commission des polices
municipales monsieur christian estrosi a
salué l'action de ce texte et la mf l'a
fait également on peut encore améliorer
bien sûr les choses
certainement sur l'expérimentation des
compétences judiciaires ce la police
municipale de paris dont chacun voit
qu'il s'agit d'un pas historique en lien
fait avec les élus parisiens même si
nous avons quelques discordances sur la
forme le fond a été saluée je remercie
le travail que nous avons pu faire et
nous feront qu avec même la maire de
paris et puis également un travail très
fort et très complet sur d'autres délits
que nous créions ou que nous empêcherons
de continuer à exister comme les
mortiers qui vous le savez bien c'est un
problème très important puisque nous
n'avons pas les moyens aujourd'hui de
lutter contre ces véritables armes par
destination le texte qui répond et je
dis monsieur présent de la commission
que nous sommes très attentifs aux
travaux du groupe centriste notamment
notamment je pense à la présidente
létard sur le protoxyde d'azoté
nous nous sommes tout à fait favorables
à son interdiction comme seul complément
de ce café dans la loi de 2018 période
contre les rodéos malheureusement à
l'assemblée nationale ces dix ans une
ppl la recevabilité n'a pas été fait par
l'assemblée ne sont pourtant que je peux
présumer de ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
comme accor il s'agit d'un lien tout
particulier avec la sécurité de nos
concitoyens et singulièrement parfois
des compétences de la police municipale
nous serions très heureux que la séance
du sénat dans sa grande sagesse accepte
évidemment ces deux dispositifs qui nous
permet d'en parler et de les approuver
surtout sachant que les sénateurs ont
très largement travaillé sur ce sujet
par des propositions de loi ou par des
rapports le deuxième sujet sur les
images avec des choses extrêmement
concrète la mise en place des ces sud et
centre de supervision urbain
intercommunaux aujourd'hui les polices
des circonscriptions de police ou
gendarmerie sont plusieurs communes
souvent il ya la grande ville et
d'autres villes plus modestes à côté
cette grande ville peut porter des
caméras de vidéo protection des murs
d'image mais le pouvoir de police qui
est délégué évidemment au maire ne peut
pas être déléguées un autre maire sauf
complexité ou sauf multiplication des
agents de police qui doit être présent
tout le temps devant la caméra nous
créons non seulement des ceo
intercommunaux avec la possibilité
évidemment qui ne correspond pas à
l'intercommunalité et bien à la vie au
bassin de vie entre communes qui le
souhaitent et même à la demande je le
dis ici de la présidente du conseil
départemental de l'oise qui en avait
fait la proposition et je salue edouard
courtial notamment qu'il apportait en
amont du texte
dc sud départementaux
pour ceux qui le souhaitent afin que les
petites communes notamment dans les
zones gendarmerie puisse porter à la
fois la protection de la vidéoprotection
sans pouvoir se ruiner ou avant les
moyens de ne pas pouvoir la sécurité en
lien évidemment avec la police nationale
la gendarmerie
il s'agit aussi de régulariser
l'utilisation des drones dont j'entends
qu'il peut faire naître des débats
importants mais dont je serais étonné
que seules les forces de l'ordre n'est
pas le droit de les utiliser
puisque à peu près tout le monde peut
utiliser un drone sauf dans des
conditions désormais pour les forces de
l'ordre puisque encore vu la récente
décision de la cnil pour le préfecture
de police de paris
il s'agirait aujourd'hui d'encadrer
l'utilisation de ces drones évidemment
qui sont des images comme les autres et
qu'ils doivent protéger bien sûr nos
concitoyens sans toucher à la vie privée
nous sommes tout à fait prêts évidemment
à discuter de tous les points de cette
proposition de loi
intéressante et enfin les caméras
piétons et sa généralisation qui permet
la meilleure utilisation des images
également pour la protection des
fonctionnaires de police ou de
gendarmerie
et pour la meilleure utilisation des
deux enquêtes on y reviendra très
certainement
enfin sur la sécurité privée il s'agit
évidemment de ne pas faire des policiers
bis mais bien de prendre au sérieux cet
acteur économique très important et une
filière qui se construit il faut
encourager qu'on doit davantage et d
aider en renforçant les contrôles et les
sanctions du cnaps qui dépend du
ministère de l'intérieur et des en
garantissant la formation la meilleure
formation de ses agents et des aussi
évidemment sur un meilleur traitement de
la moralité de ses agents des
dispositions très importantes sont
prises on aura eu de controverse et la
sous-traitance
enfin je terminerai cette intervention
en soulignant qu' évidemment le
gouvernement sera attentif à la
rédaction que proposera le sénat sur
l'article 24 de cette proposition de loi
et si le parlement sénat puis assemblés
ont évidemment tout loisir de faire ce
qu'il souhaite
dans les textes de lois qui sont soumis
à leur approbation le gouvernement par
ma voix souhaite ardemment que nous
puissions continuer à protéger nos
forces de l'ordre d'une manière ou d'une
autre et donc les opérations de police
puisque vous le savez bien c'est à mme
ces femmes et ces hommes indépendamment
de risquer leur vie pour nous sont
parfois mis en accusation est mis en
violence et il est normal que nous
puissions le protéger ce qui nous
protège
merci monsieur me dise monsieur
daubresse sur le premier oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
à mon tour je souhaite une très bonne
année et ce n'est pas un peu que vous
savez j'ai une série de questions sur
les polices municipales pour aller à
l'essentiel et puis une série de
questions sur les forces de sécurité
intérieure et notamment sur les articles
maps et suivants dont l'article 24
s'agissant des polices municipales et du
dispositif expérimental il est vrai très
très original qui est présenté les
principaux écueils que nous ont donné
nos interlocuteurs dans les très
nombreuses auditions qu'on a déjà mené
avec mon collègue loïc hervé c'est ce
problème d'élargissement à titre
expérimental des prérogatives
judiciaires
des agents de police municipale par
exemple pour saisir des stupéfiants dans
le but de renforcer vous l'aï dit le
continuum de sécurité et là on se trouve
avec une sorte d'autorité fonctionnel
qui le procureur puisqu'il s'agit d'une
action d'officier de police judiciaire
et d'autorité hiérarchique
on est dans la libre administration des
collectivités locales quelle merde c'est
le maire qui recrutent et qui créent des
polices municipales donc comment vous
voyez cela sans qu'ils aient risque de
confusion
et surtout comment moi j'ai participé à
plusieurs grands expérimentation dans ma
vie d'élu ministre
et comment voyez l'évaluation de cette
expérimentation et comment vous la
garantie ses premières questions
deuxième question l'expérimentation
prévoit une montée en puissance des
polices municipales sans avoir évoqué un
renforcement de la coopération avec les
forces nationales
est-ce que vous pensez que cela vous
paraît réellement de nature à renforcer
le continuum de sécurité et dans ce
fameux beauvau de la sécurité comment
vous envisagez de montrer la montée en
puissance respective vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure des deux forces police
nationale police municipale sans qu'on
enlève des prérogatives à l'une ou à
l'autre on va en rajouter police
municipale pour qu'elle puisse agir de
concert de manière plus efficace
troisième question sur les polices
municipales tout le monde
les syndicats de policiers ne parle le
cnfpt évidemment de la formation des
agents de police municipale et du fait
qu'il ya quand même un sérieux écueil
dans beaucoup de villes aujourd'hui deux
provinces sur la capacité de ces
policiers municipaux à écrire des procès
verbaux qui si on élargit leur
compétence doivent être tout à fait les
tribunes manière pertinente pour éviter
notamment les vices de forme et on sait
bien que les forces de police sont son
je dirais agacé plus qu'agacé par les
multiples contentieux pour vice de forme
alors qu'elle arrive à traquer des
délinquants donc comment vous voyez le
renforcement de cette formation et
dernière question sur les polices
municipales vous avez parlé de paris
effectivement je confirme et loïc hervé
était avec moi que nous avons eues et du
côté de la préfecture de police de paris
et du côté des élus et des services
parisiens
je dirais un satisfecit disons que ça
avait été très bien préparé que c'était
une vraie coproduction et que tous à
s'engager
avec ce sous des augures très favorable
la question qui reste posée vous le
savez c'est la question de la création
des polices municipales par décret en
conseil d'état ce que souhaite le
gouvernement
alors que ce qui est assez logique pour
des mains vous avez été mère et moi
aussi
on pense que ça doit être créée par
délibération des décollé de la
collectivité locale d'autant que la
ville de paris dix héros dit qu'elle
veut que ce soit un service de police
municipale de droit commun donc comment
vous pensez pouvoir évoluer là dessus
sachant qu'il ya eu des avis du conseil
d'état sur ces questions est ce que vous
pensez évolué par rapport à la position
qui était celle là votre à l'assemblée
nationale j'en viens aux questions sur
des articles 23 et 24 l'article 23
prévoit supprimer les crédits de
réductions automatiques de peines pour
les auteurs d'infractions lorsqu'elles
ont été commises au préjudice d'une
personne investie d'un mandat électif
public ou d'un militaire la gendarmerie
nationale et où d'un fonctionnaire est
ce que ce dispositif vous paraît en
adéquation avec l'objectif de diminution
est de bonne gestion de la population
carcérale puisque ce n'est plus la
gravité de l'infraction qui justifie une
plus grande sévérité quand on exécute la
peine mais la personne au préjudice de
laquelle la fraction a été commise tels
que cet écrit dans cette proposition de
là est ce que ça vous paraît respectueux
de l'échelle des plaines et enfin
dernière question sur le fameux article
24 qui nous a fait beaucoup travailler
en france avant la trêve des confiseurs
la difficulté monsieur le ministre on en
a parlé d'ailleurs on s'en est entretenu
en amont j'ai bien compris que votre
intention au départ quand vous
vous rentrez dans cet article 24 pour
mieux protéger les policiers il ya quand
même une large majorité de cette
assemblée qui souhaite qu'on protège
mieux les policiers compte tenu de tout
ce qu'ils doivent subir au quotidien
c'était de rentrer par le biais de la
loi sur la liberté de la presse pour
éviter des risques si on entrait par le
code pénal de choses plus graves sur
certains journalistes s'ils étaient
incriminés notamment sur la question de
l'aider comparution immédiate mais on
voit bien que toutes les réactions et
toutes les analyses juridiques
convergent pour dire que et sur le
respect et sur le principe de nécessité
proportionnalité constitutionnelle d'une
part et de l'article 10 de la convention
des droits de l'homme d'autres pas on a
un vrai problème d'équilibré cette
maison il est très attaché entre les
libertés fondamentales d'un côté
évidemment le renforcement de l'autorité
de l'autre côté
donc nous en arrivons tous aux
conclusions qu'il faut quand même entré
par le code pénal mais si on rentre par
le code pénal pour mieux protéger les
policiers
il faut évidemment que l'on puisse ne
résoudre le problème de maintien de la
liberté d'informer surtout qu'on ne met
pas sa sueur qu'on mette pas ça sur une
incrimination liés aux opérations de
police dont alors votre collègue garde
des sceaux eric dupond moretti a écrit
enfin ses services et lui ont proposé à
la fin de ce mois à l'assemblée
nationale un article 25 de 18 sur les
valeurs de la république qui va dans ce
sens avec une incrimination général et
une peine aggravée quand il s'agit de
fonctionnaires dépositaires de
l'autorité publique la difficulté allez
c'est pas nous qui avons choisi l'ordre
du jour nous nous étions prêts à
débattre dès la fin de ce mois mais
l'assemblée va débattre à la fin du mois
de la loi sur les valeurs de la
république nous allons être saisie mi
mars de la question des de la loi sur la
sécurité globale
comment vous voyez l'articulation entre
ces deux textes ampleur est ce que le
gouvernement fait lui une liaison entre
l'article 24 tel qu'il est écrit qu'on
pourrait
mieux écrire et avec une entrée je le
redis par le biais du code pénal d'une
part et d'autre part avec l'article
d'hier article 18
il va être proposé dans clair est-ce que
le gouvernement sa position byron vous
va être de dire peut-être me répondrait
pour pas tout de suite mais de dire bah
finalement nous notre réponse c'est
l'article 18 de la loi sur les valeurs
de la république voilà ma question
merci monsieur merci monsieur présent
monsieur le ministre à mon tour de vous
présenter mes meilleurs voeux ainsi qu'à
l'ensemble des collègues pour notre
première séance de la commission des
lois de l'année nouvelle
en complément de ce qui a été dit par
marc philippe daubresse et avant
d'aborder les trois sujets qui m'échoit
je voudrais d'abord vous dire que vous
avez évoqué le travail que nous avons
déjà mené parce que comme marc philippe
vient de l'évoquer
nous prévoyons d'avoir ce texte en
janvier nous le rend mardi nous avons
davantage de temps pour mener des
auditions c'est d'autant plus important
que nous le fassions puisque c'est une
proposition de loi et que par définition
ce texte n'a pas connu d'étude d'impact
ni de passage en conseil d'état
encore moins des avis de la cnil
d'ailleurs je remercie président de la
commission des lois qui a saisi la cnil
d'un avis et nous aurons nous
auditionneront la la présidente
la commission nationale informatique et
libertés forte de la vie que la
commission rendra sur le texte dans sa
mouture de sortie de l'assemblée
nationale sert la matière que nous
étudions ici ici ou au sénat petite
remarque
moi je trouve le tel est le titre de ce
texte de loi absolument horrible je me
demande qui a qui l'a inventé
c'est pas vous j'imagine monsieur le
ministre mais enfin à voir celui qui a
trouvé l'adjectif épithètes à mettre à
côté de sécurité mettrait à défaut d'une
médaille une sévère correction parce que
c'est pas c'est pas comme ça qu'on vend
un texte et je sais que vous avez dit un
certain nombre de choses qui sont de
l'ordre de la louange par rapport à un
certain nombre de choses qui sont
intéressantes au demeurant dans le texte
mais enfin c'est quoi tes global c'est
un peu fort de café
bref j'en viens à mes trois sujets
d'abord la sécurité privée vous demander
au parlement d'habilité le gouvernement
a réformé le cnaps donc le conseil
national des activités de sécurité
privée par ordonnance bon est ce que c
est ce que pour vous c'est aussi
important
on savait qu'on n'aime pas dans cette
maison le recours aux ordonnances et est
ce que ce d'ici le mois de mars il y
aurait pas d un certain nombre de choses
dans la réforme du cnaps moi je commence
à avoir un stand d'éléments de pistes de
réformes qui pourraient être mis en dur
dans la loi et puis de réserver un
certain nombre de choses plus +
accessoire alors donnant sur la sécurité
privée toujours l'assemblée nationale
est allé plus loin que ce qui était
prévu dans le projet de loi initial soit
qu'ils sont vous avez évoqué de la sous
traitance
que pensez-vous de la solution retenue
par l'assemblée nationale
et est-ce qu'il vous paraît réaliste par
rapport à un secteur économique dans
lequel le recours en cas de à la sous
traitance en cascade est devenu monnaie
courante et pose de vraies difficultés
mais il s'agit quand même d'un domaine
privé cepdendant le terme il faut
réguler l'activité privée ce bien bien
sûr le principe que nous devons quand
même respecter et et dont le plus
généralement on vous l'avait évoqué
aussi quelle est la place que vous
envisagez pour les agents c'est qu'ils
ont été privés dans le cadre de contes
du continuum de sécurité est ce que vous
envisagez d'autres élargissements et à
quel moment vous mettez une limite en
disant que
les choses relèvent du service public
proprement dit et qu'ils doivent être
assumés par des policiers par des
gendarmes ou par des fonctionnaires
territoriaux que sont les policiers
municipaux
j'en viens maintenant la question des
drones la proposition de loi instaure un
cadre spécifique
la jurisprudence administrative la plus
récente démontre s'il le fallait
la nécessité d'avoir un ancrage
juridique pour l'utilisation des drones
les matériels sont déjà dans les
services de police et de gendarmerie
sont utilisés je suis un élu de montagne
vous le savez vous êtes +11 élus de
territoire qui sont proches de la mer et
et danse en montagne comme sur les
littoraux du pays
il est utile d'avoir des drones pour
notamment des questions de sauvetage il
est utile d'avoir des drones pour des
questions de surveillance des frontières
il est utile d'avoir des drones pour
aussi le raid ou au gign et et
évidemment il n'est pas question de
remettre en cause ce type d'utilisation
et d'ailleurs c'est nécessaire d'avoir
un dans le droit
quelque chose qui le permettent en
revanche dès qu'on va commencer à
toucher leur public les questions de vie
privée
la prévention des infractions à ce
moment là parce que si vous regardez le
texte gentil de l'assemblée on a quand
même une espèce de liste à la prévert
qui met un peu tous dans le même sac
la liste est impressionnante et donc je
pense qu'il ya des sujets sur lesquels
il ya un consensus qui se dégage
facilement et la technologie est au
service du service public et elle est
également au service de des citoyens en
revanche quand on va commencer à risque
et d'atteindre certaines libertés
publiques notamment les questions de vie
privée
alors il faut ce qu'il faut aux minimes
à s'armer de dispositifs de garantie et
de préservation des libertés publiques
au moins deux hommes annie minima de
contrôle ou d'encadrement et la loi doit
un mode de mon point de vue le faire et
c'est ce que nous essayons de réfléchir
avec ma fille nous reste pour avoir
quelque chose qui soit équilibrée entre
la nécessité d'avoir une je redis à nos
cadres un ancrage législatif pour les
drones n'ont même pas une plus grande
protection des libertés publiques
enfin sur les cas
les caméras mobiles on nous avons eu ici
les deux directeurs généraux de la
police et de la gendarmerie c'est
quelque chose qui est utile quel bilan
faites-vous déjà 2 de cet usage pour les
agents qu'ils utilisent d'ores et déjà
on a eu envie de remonter sur la qualité
des matériels des remontées aussi sur le
rôle réel quelques ces caméras quand
elles sont portés on dans la la
pacification des relations qui paye
entre les forces de sécurité et les
citoyens
et puis bon on doit vraiment
j'insisterai beaucoup là dessus se poser
la question de la qualité de deux de ces
matériels est-ce qu'on arrivera par
exemple avoir des vies des matériels
français ou européens suffisamment bien
conçu avec des matériaux de qualité pour
que la charge tiennent que les capacités
de mémoire soit suffisante et qu'on est
donc des matériels qui soit efficient
robuste et qui par leur utilisation
puisse être utilisée utilisé à bon
escient
et puis est ce que vous pensez aussi que
quelque part les agents ou les
supérieurs archives devraient avoir
accès plus rapidement aux images
contenues dans l'est dans les terminaux
est ce qu'il faut est vraiment dans une
logique de séparation du porteur la
caméra et de celui qui utilise ces
images aussi vous pensez au contraire
que où qu'on pourrait permettre dans un
certain nombre de cas de figure le
rapatriement ou l'exploitation des
images beaucoup plus rapidement afin de
de permettre de résoudre des problèmes
je pense à une lecture de plaques
d'identité à une personne qui a été
rencontrée avec laquelle il ya une
difficulté quelconque omg milices les
quelques questions je voulais poser sur
ces trois sujets qui sont ceux dont j'ai
la charge dans ce dans cette proposition
de loi merci merci aussi à réceptionner
issus de la parole et puis ensuite j'ai
deux demandes de parole merci monsieur
le président alors monsieur daubresse
ces votes les questions des polices
municipales d'abord en me demandant
comment on garantit l'expérimentation
comme on la généralise qu'il s'agisse
ici la partie premier une
expérimentation quand même très large en
trois ans
avec très peu de condition puisque c'est
la loi qui comme défini beaucoup de
critères au moins 20 policiers
municipaux un chef de service qu'on
verra pourquoi ça répond notamment à
votre question des procès verbaux et
évidemment sur volonté des élus de
pouvoir obtenir cette expérimentation et
c'était tel sorte puisqu'on a déjà passé
quasiment une année ne demanda municipal
le temps que la loi soit votée que les
décrets soient pris ce sera sans doute
une deuxième année il faut bien le dire
et donc trois ans serait correspondre au
mandat des maires actuels si en plus
soucieux du respect démocratique des
électeurs donc il nous semble nous que
c'est une bonne disposition
d'expérimentation assez long pour avoir
un certain nombre de vérités en tirer
des conclusions
est-ce qu'on a souhaité c'est évidemment
de sa pole sa confiance aux élus locaux
de pas rendre obligatoire des députés le
souhaitait rendre obligatoires les
polices municipales en obligatoire
police municipale armée en obligatoire
des compétences supplémentaires
on a souhaité que ce soit à la carte ce
qui montre bien qu'il s'agit de choix
locaux et que l'état garde quoi qu'il
arrive le monopole c'est choisir de la
sécurité intérieure sur la montée en
puissance plus évoqués il s'agit pas
effectivement de pouvoir rentrer dans
des enquêtes judiciaires mais il s'agit
de résoudre des problèmes de bon sens
nous avons mis en place amendes
forfaitaires délictuelle pour les
consommateurs de stupéfiants dans les
cas où ces personnes ne sont pas soit
portant une grosse quantité de
stupéfiants s'est inscrit par procureur
de la république à chaque ressort de
parquet soit pour montrer qu'ils ne sont
pas des trafiquants ou des utilisateurs
répétitif de ces consommations quelqu'un
qui fume un joint dans la rue le
policier national peut verbaliser pas le
policier municipal que phil ty soit il
était temps des yeux soit il retient à
cette personne ou décès doit dire cette
personne sage et que par ailleurs la
retenue des personnes près police
municipale quelque chose de complexe
pour appeler le policier national qui va
émettre l'amande bon c'est être pas
voilà ce qu'on appelle absurde il
policiers municipaux ont la compétence
pour mettre à procès verbal sous
l'autorité pour le coup du procureur de
la république il s'agit évidemment d'une
inscription par ailleurs et c'est pas
une simple amende c'est vrai mais c'est
quelque chose de constater voilà ça
tombe de fait aussi bête que joue si
j'ose dire qu'il permette aux policiers
municipaux d'avoir ses compétences
supplémentaires sans rentrer dans la
police judiciaire dans la compétence
judiciaire à proprement parler donc je
crois qu'on aura l'occasion de parler de
ces détails mais c'est j'ai vraiment dû
du bon sens le plus de plus élémentaires
sur la capacité des policiers municipaux
a créé ad bon procès verbaux qu'ils vont
évidemment transmettre le texte prévoit
au portland de la république sarpourenx
importantes qui pourraient se tourner
d'abord sur les policiers nationaux les
gendarmes et pas tellement à cause des
compétences des policiers nationaux
desjardins mais par notre manque
d'organisation une autre mauvaise
organisation ministre de l'intérieur je
le prends pour moi et nous allons
réformer ça nous réformons sens moment
des au pgi d'abord le chef
on a dans le bourg et la sécurité en
parallèle d'encadrement paraît tout à
fait essentiel un chef c'est fait pour
chercher des annonces un président de la
république est là pour relire et pour
corriger les procès verbaux de ses
collaborateurs que sont les gardiens de
la paix où les gendarmes de terrain il
n'est pas simplement là pour transmettre
au procureur de la république quoi son
substitut évidemment des enquêtes temps
beaucoup de mauvaises réponses pénales
vu du côté policier y'a pas que les
difficultés la justice il ya aussi des
policiers des gendarmes qui rédige mal
des procès verbaux ne sont pas tout à
fait aux hauts faits des vices de forme
que les avocats bien évidemment ou que
les procureurs la réplique aux les juges
constatent et qui sont à constater
donc il ya d'abord un travail très
important de pj à mettre en face des
demandes des policiers et des gendarmes
et beaucoup d'entre vous d'ailleurs me
réclame indépendamment des effectifs des
objets dans vos territoires
mais indépendamment de sa ce qu'on a
prévu c'est pas que le policier
municipal transmette au procureur la
république c'est pour ça qu'il faut un
directeur ou un chef de service dans
l'expérimentation que nous souhaitons
parce que ce directeur chef de service
qui est une grande compétence et
quiconque a dirigé une police municipale
sait très bien que à plus de 20
policiers municipaux
c'est souvent des anciens officiers de
gendarmerie des anciens gradés de la
police nationale ou à savoir une
personne qui passe des concours
extrêmement difficile spécifique
d'ailleurs chacun le sait puisqu'il
s'agit d'une fonction publique qui
connaît un concours particulier qui peut
avoir les compétences juridiques pour
transmettre dans la république c'est
procès verbaux et donc ainsi répondre à
la demande que vous évoquez de sérieux
et que je partage même si avec il ya
évidemment les formations que nous
devons à chaque agent publics nationaux
comme locaux
sur la ville de paris permettez moi
monsieur le rapporteur d'avoir une
légère différence d'appréciation
il me semble que la création de la
police municipale relève de la
délibération du conseil de paris
là sur ce point je ne saurais vous
donnez temps mais comme toute façon je
ne sais pas dans quelle commune de
france
en revanche les statuts de la police
municipale relève du décret en conseil
d'état comme toutes les polices
municipales donc il n'ya pas de
d'inéquité avec les autres territoires
je rajouterais à dire que paris est par
nature
d'abord parce que c'est une collectivité
sui generis comme chacun sait puis par
nature un endroit particulier où la
sécurité publique est particulière c'est
à dire conserver une préfecture de
police sans doute dans paris la petite
couronne et que l'état et c'est bien
normal je crois que le maire de paris
dont on convient mérite d'avoir un oeil
particulier ou sans tout ce que c'est
parce que nous n'avions pas confiance
dans la ville de paris depuis très
longtemps que nous n'ayons pas de des
forces armées à la mer dont j'ai compris
que par ailleurs elle ne souhaitait pas
elle
et c'est un autre débat politique moi je
souhaite que nous respectons la volonté
d'aller de paris de ne pas armer sa
police municipale
et si demain madame la maire de paris et
son conseil de paris où une autre
majorité ce très armée la police
municipale de paris prendra une
délibération évidemment dans des
conditions qui sont elles mêmes de
toutes les collectivités donc il faut
distinguer je crois la création de la
police de ses statuts je constaterai
d'ailleurs que la ville de paris c'est
un corps de fonctionnaires particulier
qui ne relèvent pas en tant que tel de
la fonction publique territoriale
d'ailleurs qui ne payent pas les mêmes
tribus si j'ose dire au cnfpt etc
j'y reviendrai pas donc il ya un statut
sujet des risques il nous faut adapter
mais s'agit pas de sardines équité entre
la ville de paris
bien sûr et les autres collectivités sur
les questions d'équité entre entre
détenus environ entre condamnation
moi je ne sommes pas rentrés par des
aggravations qui existe déjà deux
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique ou subies par les personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique mais
par les remises de peine
donc nous avons souhaité qu'il n'y ait
pas de remises de peines et le texte
pour les personnes qui ont atteint des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique
donc il ne paraît pas très différent de
ce qui existe déjà c'est déjà des
différenciations une fonction aggrave
entre que d'agresser un policier un
gendarme ou toute autre personne qui a
une autorité publique comme un élu comme
vous le savez donc il ne semble pas
d'inéquité sur ce point d'ailleurs je
voudrais dire que c'est avec le garde
des sceaux que nous avons rédigé
évidemment ce cette proposition de
consensus puisque l'idée des
parlementaires dans un premier temps et
l aggravation où les peines planchers
pour ceux qui attaquaient les
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
selon l'article 24 mois j'ai pas de
fétichisme en général monsieur le
ministre et en particulier sur l'article
24 25 18
mais je voudrais quand même dire quelque
chose quelques idées simples vers un
débat compliqué bon d'abord je voudrais
heureux souligné mais vous l'avez fait
vous même la grande importance de
protéger nos forces de l'ordre puisque
nous leur devons et je rappelle le drame
de magnanville qui concerne pas
simplement les forces de l'ordre mais
également ceux qui concourent
je rappelle que madame schneider était
une policière entre guillemets elles
étaient personnels techniques
administratifs scientifiques et pour le
terroriste qui a cherché entité qu'à
retrouver entité égorgé devant son
enfant c'est ça le drame de magnanville
je vous envoie sur le site copwatch
notamment une dans notre région où on a
listé les policiers leur photo leur nom
leur prénom et et dans des conditions
qui ne donne pas de doute que c'est pas
pour envoyer des chocolats pour noël
ça va à peu près évident donc il faut
protéger ces policiers que l'article 24
ut été mal rédigé bien sûr sinon nous
serions pas dans ceux dans cette
discussion mais je voudrais quand même
dire que si je comprends l'idée du sénat
et d'autres parlementaires d'aller dans
le code pénal je m'étonne ça ne veut pas
dire que je ne souscrirai pas
éventuellement la rédaction proposerait
par l'assemblée et le sénat
parce que le code pénal a comme énorme
avantage c'est vrai de sortir du code de
la presse et donc de sortir l'idée
qui n'est pas une idée réelle mais quand
je suis bien obligé de voir est une idée
perçue que les journalistes ou les gens
qui veulent informer puisse être
concernés le code pénal c'est permet la
garde à vue
ce que ne permet pas le code de la
presse et permet de la comparution
immédiate ce que permet pas le code de
la presse donc j'entends que le code
pénal est en fait la solution en fait va
choisir la plus dure quand dispositions
qui relèvent du code de la presse donc
je mets se soumet sa la sagacité des
législateurs je signe un deuxième point
qui me paraît important c'est que dans
cette possibilité de voir le code de la
presse c'était une cohérence avec la
protection déjà des identités des
policiers des gendarmes
il ya déjà des articles qui protège
notamment ceux qui mettent des cagoules
et qui se cachent leur identité
notamment dans l'anti terrorisme ou dans
la grande criminalité
quand ils interviennent la protection
d'identité des policiers des gens à
mettre déjà dans le code de la presse
donc une fois que j'ai dit ça je
comprends bien je n'ai pas fait
tellement de politique et j'avais
beaucoup de droits mais je le souligne
c'est pour ça j'essaie de vous expliquer
pourquoi le gouvernement n'a pas à
l'assemblée souhaitait aller vers les
propositions du code pénal qui était
d'ailleurs très partagée par parler par
les parlementaires sur la question que
vous posez de est-ce qu'on peut
fusionner l'article 24 avec l'article 25
de nu 18 bon moi j'y suis très
défavorables n'ont pas encore une fois
pour des raisons de texte ou de
fétichisme ils n'atteignent pas des
mêmes buts
l'article 24 prévoit la protection des
fonctionnaires de police ou les
militaires la gendarmerie dans des
opérations de police le législateur
d'assemblée ailleurs ajouté policiers
municipaux
on pourrait imaginer douaniers certains
voulaient administration pénitentiaire
mais dans opération de police s'agit pas
des protégés en tant que policier ou en
tant que gendarme en tant que tel ça ils
le sont par les dispositions qui sont
effectivement ceux du code mais dans les
opérations de police par exemple fait
déjà mille exemples que nous avons
connue sur internet il suffit de
regarder les choses là-dessus pour s'en
convaincre
est-ce que c'était bien rédigé la
réponse est non mais il y avait un but
et ce but était celui explique l'article
l'article 25 2018 répond pas simplement
policiers aux gendarmes et à toute
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique
j'ai tendance à penser malgré la grande
qualité
je suis très respectueux des élus les
magistrats de toute personne comme une
autorité publique mais elle n'est pas de
la même à mon avis manière que de ce
qu'ils risquent chaque jour dans des
opérations de police des interventions
ne serait ce que parce qu'ils sont armés
ou parce que ils vont au contact en
premier lieu avec un certain nombre de
faits ça ses premiers points
deuxièmement ce que prévoit l'article 25
de 18 c'est la possible de protéger
l'individu et sa famille puisque ce
n'est pas le cas des articles 24 et puis
troisièmement il ya derb immédiatement
quai dans l'article 25 de nuit 18 parce
qu'il s'agit exactement d'un jeu dit
comme ça pardon mais d'un article samuel
pâtit il ya la fatwa numérique lancée
par le père jeune nina qui évoque l'
identité lors d'une personne qui n'est
pas dépositaire de l'autorité publique
en l'occurrence qui est un enseignant
m'enfin l'occurrence qu'elle enseigne en
lui donnant son identité
disons qu'il aurait fait des choses avec
l'affirmation et à créer les conditions
en rompant avec son sa vie privée son
identité en tant que fonctionnaire à la
des conditions de certain nombre de
réponses bien sûr malheureuse qui sont
qui sont qui sont arrivés et donc ça
peut être le cas pour des magistrats ça
peut être le cas pour plein de personnes
dont des policiers et des gendarmes et
pas simplement
il me semble donc ces deux articles
différents dont j'entends et j'ai lu ce
que va faire le sénat nous regarderons
évidemment cela je ne connais pas la
position finale du gouvernement puisque
je ne connais pas votre rédaction et
votre proposition mais nous souhaitons
en tout cas différentiel et les deux
textes puis qu'ils n'apportent pas les
mêmes vues évoqué sur la question de les
questions ne sera porteur sur le cnaps
j'entends que les ordonnances ne
réjouissent pas des parlementaires je
l'entends bien volontiers il s'agit
cependant baron vient d'avouer d'un bon
moment d'une possibilité d'un
gouvernement de pouvoir légiférer sur
l'octave donc la proposition doit être
arrivée nous nous sommes saisis de cela
c'est la proposition que nous vous
faisons éclairé par les débats
parlementaires et par les habilitations
voudrait bien donner sur une
mobilisation très importante sur la
structuration il faut beaucoup discuté
avec une finale provinciale que vous
avez rencontrés et qui est parfois un
peu éparses pas toujours structuré comme
on le souhaiterait et nous sommes là
pour les aider à se restructurer sur des
questions de sanction des questions de
formation
ce que je peux proposer monsieur le
rapporteur s'est non seulement
d'éclairer très largement les débats
pour être dans le sens que vous
souhaitez mais vous associez ville
le plus étroitement possible pour que
nous allions le plus rapidement possible
et prendre le temps quand même de
structurer une véritable filière
professionnelle qui le méritent et dont
j'ai compris que vous souhaitiez vous
aussi voir quelles étaient les limites
et vous l'avez évoqué les limites il est
assez clair il faut évidemment que il
n'est pas de pouvoir de contrainte me
paraît très important de pas de ne
pouvoir nous constater des délits bien
évidemment on ne pourra pas faire de
portes dans quête bien sûr ne pourra pas
pas privé de liberté des personnes et
donc de pouvoir se tenir strictement aux
compétences de sécurité privées de
surveillance mais qui sont essentiels
imaginez qu'il faille mettre des
policiers municipaux et nationaux des
gendarmes dans chaque grand magasin dans
chaque festival que nous connaissons
tous dans nos territoires et concours
bien évidemment dans notre vie locale il
concourt évidemment à la halle à la
sécurité de nos concitoyens tout en
limitant évidemment leur pouvoir à ceux
de l'état régalien ou des collectivités
locales sur les drones bon moi je
souhaite que ni lui ni moi on puisse
donner au moins les moyens vous l'avez
dit vous-même un cadre juridique qui
nous permettent de fonctionner comme des
caméras de vidéoprotection serait
étonnant qu'on puisse donner des moyens
juridiques de surveillance des caméras
de vidéoprotection désormais la plus
grand monde qui contestent le fait
qu'elles sont efficaces et qu'elles sont
utiles dans la résolution des crimes et
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
d'évident pour de ses moyens de vos
moyens technologiques alors il faut vous
dites une liste à la prévert tout à fait
prêt à mettre davantage de garanties
peut-être que le texte de l'assemblée
n'est pas assez propre à garder les
garanties je pense notamment en lien
avec la le domicile privé ne sont pas
assez limité sans doute et permettrait
d'être éclairée par le par le sénat sans
aucun doute mais je crois que c'est les
cas d'usagés que nous avons listé et si
je devais comparer de ce que font nos
voisins qui pourtant ne sont pas d'
affreuse dictature numérique
les danois les suédois les utilisent
pour les finalités judiciaire pour le
maintien de l'ordre et les espagnols
c'est exactement la même finalité que
prévu de la proposition de loi que nous
évoquons donc beaucoup de gouvernements
avant nous et vous que le parlement
avant nous avant légiférer sur les
drones nous sommes un des derniers pays
d'ailleurs la cnil nous l'a reproché de
patrouilleurs de base légale d'avoir un
encadrement des drones sans jamais qu'il
n'y ai d'ailleurs la reconnaissance
faciale puisque
beaucoup de choses qu'il évoquait ce
sujet et il est évidemment pas prévu
dans ce texte dans ce texte de loi sur
le bilan des caméras l'un terminerai par
la piéton un petit peu tôt parce que
alors toutes les brigades de gendarmerie
de police n'ont pas des caméras vous
avez vu quand j'analyse généralisé au
1er juillet 2021 et vous avez dû
entendre les auditions il suffit d'aller
voir les policiers les gendarmes pour
voir que c'est que josse qui apaise qui
apaise de fonctionnaires et qui apaise
la personne qui est en face parce qu'une
fois que la caméra est allumée et que
tout est enregistré évidemment pour la
suite et notamment pour l'autorité
judiciaire ce sont des éléments probants
d'ailleurs chacun sait que dans le même
fait filmer ou pas filmé par une caméra
de vidéo protection
on a une réponse en général judiciaire
qui est différente et que la parole du
policier ou la parole du gendarme du
plessis municipal n'est jamais aussi
forte que la caméra qui montre aux
magistrats souvent les faits moi je
souhaiterais que ces caméras d'abord les
changes techniquement vous avez raison
sont plutôt mauvais matériel et qu'il
n'est pas conforme aux heures
d'utilisation des brigades alors qu'en
général alors deux points il faut
d'abord entrer son numéro héroïne c'est
à dire le numéro qu'on les
identifications qu'on les policiers ce
qui n'est pas super évident surtout
qu'il ne s'agit pas ici d'écrans
tactiles
donc on met plus de temps imaginé une
somme en intervention il faut entrer son
numéro au moment où vous êtes dans une
rixe
c'est quand même pas le truc le plus
simple à faire dans l'attention du
moment surtout si vous courez que vous
voulez vite avec votre véhicule pour
arrêter cette personne une fois que vous
avez appuyé sur le bouton
certes ça film quelques secondes après
quelques sur quelques secondes avant
mais votre batterie se décharge
extrêmement rapidement et si vous
laisser allumer la caméra parce que
justement le pam est le numéro en moins
de deux heures au moins deux heures et
demie ce dépendrait des modèles ba la
brigade continue son travail mais la
khadra ne fonctionne plus et donc j'ai
lancé un nouvel appel d'offres pour
renouveler l'intégralité de ses caméras
pour qu'elles faisaient évidemment je ne
sais pas s'ils sont françaises et
européennes les appels d'offres vous le
savez bien sont assez encadré mais nous
souhaitons la solution la plus la plus
la plus efficace possible d'avoir
évidemment déjà un délai plus long pour
pouvoir filmer et que les images
puissent être utilisés de manière un peu
différente d'avant 1
le fonctionnaire ne doit en aucun cas
pouvoir les modifier c'était prévu dans
l'appel d'offres c'est très clair cet
écrit
l'appel d'offres est publié chacun peut
le constater 2
ils sont évidemment transmis à
l'autorité judiciaire lorsqu'il ya une
difficulté ou à l'autorité
administrative lorsqu'il ya des enquêtes
du gpl de l'hygiène 3 elle pourrait être
revu sans être modifié parce que dans le
feu de l'action on peut avoir un détail
qu'on n'a pas vu les couleurs des
baskets la plaque d'immatriculation le
modèle de la voiture qui permet de
renseigner et d'éviter des crimes et
délits qui pourraient se reconnaître
juste après là on doit prendre la caméra
on doit aller au commissariat on doit la
poser et doivent télécharger on voit
jamais les images
et puis 4 dans les mauvais rapports
qu'évoquer monsieur le ministre de
bresse avec raison il ya parfois des
moments où le fonctionnaire il n'a pas
fait exprès de faire mes rapports
simplement chacun sait que son souvenir
est parfois différent dans l'attention
que reposer et ma paraît normal que sans
pouvoir modifier les images
le fonctionnaire puisse rédiger son
rapport en regardant ces images pour
pouvoir se dire que oui c'est lui qui a
donné le coup c'est pour lui qu'a donnée
du coup comment ça s'est passé
ce qui n'empêche pas évidemment que
l'autorité judiciaire fera son propre
avis sur les dispositions et sans les
dispositions et chétive que la ppl
évoque ne pourrions pas faire ces
transformations prévues dans l'appel
d'offres mais pas de façon dirimante si
le parlement choisissez de ne pas donner
ses pouvoirs au ministère de l'intérieur
ne modifieront pas l'appel d'offres et
nous avons pas présumer du vote des
parlementaires
merci monsieur le ministre alors j'ai
plusieurs noms de questions d'abord
madame lherbier puis ensuite madame
assassi adam gatel madame boyer mal
avait rien et monsieur durand
je vous invite les questions courtes
question au revoir répondre moi je
voudrais revenir sur l'autorisation les
visages des détrône évidemment
surveiller le territoire les frontières
la montagne etc
les maires ça paraît plus qu évident que
c'est quand même un matériel efficace
alors pour la surveillance de l'ordre
public des manifestations et des
regroupements violent ça me semble aussi
être très pertinente s'en servir bien
sûr renforcer les encadrer alors en
principe les citoyens doivent être
informés lorsqu'ils sont soumis à des
captations vidéo dans des espaces
publics ça semble tout à fait faisable
pour garantir que ces captations vidéo à
grand angle de vue
on peut être pas sur les libertés et sur
la vie privée ne peut-on pas envisager
un renforcement du rôle du procureur
je suis juriste comme beaucoup ici dans
cette salle je pense que le procureur
est là pour garantir un maximum le le
bon usage des images et on le fait bien
pour les cesu pourquoi pas avoir cette
confiance en la vie l autorisation ou
gmc du rôle du procureur merci madame
madame assassi merci monsieur le
président à mon tour je vous présente un
site à l'ensemble de nos collègues de la
commission et le personnel qui nous
accompagne tous les meilleurs voeux pour
cette nouvelle année tous les voeux
aussi monsieur le ministre et je
remarque que j'étais très attentive à
vos propos liminaire mais je remarque
que vous défendez cette proposition de
loi comme s'il s'agissait d'un projet de
loi j'ai deux questions rapides
la première c'est pour revenir sur le
très controversé article 24 dans une
lettre qui a été adressée aux membres de
notre commission et au président
particulièrement madame la commissaire
aux droits de l'homme du conseil de
l'europe critique vertement le texte de
cet article estimant qu'ils portent
atteinte à la liberté et au droit à la
liberté d'expression laquelle inclut la
liberté d'informer et que ce texte est
de nature à aggraver la crise de
confiance entre une partie de la
population une partie des forces de
l'ordre ce qui ne serait concourir à la
protection de ces dernières je ne fais
que citer le contenu de son courrier
monsieur le ministre j'aimerais savoir
comment vous recevez les critiques de
ses critiques de madame la commissaire
aux droits de l'homme du conseil de
l'europe
deuxième question très rapidement est ce
que je vais pas revenir sur les fichiers
et des questions ont été posées et des
réponses apportées même si elles ne
satisfont pas sûr bien évidemment tout
le débat s'est cristallisé sur l'article
il n'en reste pas moins que ce texte
consacre le principe d'une montée en
puissance de la sécurité privée sur
notre territoire
alors vous justifié cela par la
possibilité de conflit
des agents de sécurité privés des tâches
indues accomplit actuellement par des
gendarmes ou par des policiers nationaux
je rappelle quand même que le plus
souvent ces tâches indues sont celles
que d'autres administrations ne peuvent
assumer aurait en raison d'un manque des
moyens alors bien évident de moyens bien
alors bien évidemment certains syndicats
de police vous soutiennent mais comme
l'expliqué le sociologue christian
mouhanna et il dit simplement en se
déchargeant des tâches indues les
syndicats de police se font manger la
laine sur le dos ils ne voient pas que
tout cela s'inscrit dans une logique de
suppression des emplois publics
les policiers pensent qu'ils vont être
déchargé de certaines tâches en réalité
leur profession se fait vider de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre que
pensez vous de ce processus de
privatisation accélérée de notre
sécurité publique
merci ma gueule merci monsieur le
président merci de vos voeux monsieur le
ministre à vous et à tous ceux qui vous
entourent je suis aussi une année la
plus sereine possible mon propos et en
écho à ce que disait notre collègue
daubresse sur l'ancrage territorial de
la sécurité sur lequel la délégation
collectivités territoriales achève un
rapport alors ce sont à la fois des
questions mais aussi des remarques chi
très heureuse que vous ayez entendu la
volonté la défense de la mmf de cette
idée que la police municipale en tout
cas cette création relève d'un libre
choix et de la libre administration des
collectivités qu'on ne saurait imposer
des créations de police municipale pour
que l'état en quelque sorte se décharge
de ce qui est avant tout une fonction
reagan ne sait pas que c'est votre idée
mais ça peut être le danger qui nous
guette
on a une vraie question monsieur min sur
la formation des policiers municipaux et
notamment sur leur formation continue et
la coopération avec la police ou la
gendarmerie et mon autre question porte
sur le continuum de sécurité dans les
territoires dits ruraux en tout cas non
urbain il y avait hier un article dans
le figaro
qui met en avant l'augmentation du
nombre de délits et de la délinquance
dans des zones rurales parce que on va
dire les axes routiers amène aussi des
délinquants tout cas c'est un fait donc
comment monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
nous assurer que dans des territoires
dits ruraux la gendarmerie ou la police
continueront à être là sachant que ces
deux institutions sont de plus en plus
souvent occupé par des tâches et des
enquêtes judiciaires qui fait que leur
visibilité sur le terrain est un peu
réduite et dans les territoires en ingré
questions sur votre projet je dis pas
qu'il n'est pas bon mais il a besoin
d'être expliquée de bassins de
délinquance qui effectivement très
logique et en même temps d'une nouvelle
répartition entre la police et la
gendarmerie la gendarmerie ayant dans
nos territoires un avantage énorme c'est
que les gendarmes vivent au milieu de la
population
il participe à la vie associative leurs
enfants vont à l'école et qu'il
participe de ce fait un rôle
enfin une fonction éducative et de
prévention qui me semble extrêmement
importante je vous remercie
merci à madame boyer puis mais n'avait
rien ensuite
il a allumé la merci donc monsieur le
ministre
en ce qui me concerne je voudrais vous
parler de migration l'immigration parce
que je pense qu'il y avait urgence je
voudrais vous parler du nombre de titres
de séjour qui sont délivrés chaque année
à des ressortissants de pays qui
n'appartiennent pas à l'union européenne
ces chiffres ne sont pas dissimuler mais
ils sont rarement analysé dans une
perspective de long terme et alors on
peut pas en parler
alors j'ai une question sur la
répartition même si c'est pas dans le
texte parce que ça concerne je pensais
qu'on pouvait parler de plusieurs sujets
monsieur le président allez j'y vais
l'envoyer continue vous prenez l'argent
rapidement alors rapidement même pour un
lien avec le texte met rapidement si
c'est pas dans le texte
je voulais vous parler justement dollar
et par nous donner quelques idées si
vous voulez mais effectivement de la
répartition de ce que vous appelez de
des migrants surnuméraires ou surdotées
dans dans les régions puisque paris est
sûr dotées donc puisque c'est pas dans
le texte
j'y reviendrai ultérieurement mais oui
oui posez votre question je continue ma
question est donc merci mes chers
collègues donc je ne voudrais pas
enfreindre les règles de la commission
bon alors je recommence donc tout ce que
je voudrais je voudrais quand même
rappeler que ces chiffres sont quand
même extrêmement important puisque on
est passé d'un peu moins de 150 milles
en 2000 à 2 174 mille en 2019 soit une
progression de 83%
aucune autre grandeur significative de
notre population de notre économie n'a
évolué de la même manière
de même le nombre annuaire des
demandeurs d'asile est passé d'un peu
moins de 40 milles en 2000 à 132 1800 en
2019 soit une multiplication par trois
points 33 ans 20 ans ces chiffres
montrent que les vingt dernières années
les vingt dernières années oui les
premières années du siècle ont vu la
formation d'une vague migratoire de très
grande ampleur
le nombre d'immigrés en 2018 était
d'environ 6,8 millions et selon l'insee
la population immigrée qui représentait
5% du total de la population de la
france en 46 ans représente cet ennemi
en 2000 presque 10% en 2018 soit un
quasi doublement depuis la libération
je veux pas vous faire
parler de chiffres trop longtemps mais
je voudrais juste vous rappeler que
pendant un mandat qui vous est cher
puisque vous y fait très régulièrement
référence donc après le retour au
ministère de l'intérieur de nicolas
sarkozy la france ne délivraient plus
que 171 1000 titres de séjour contre 192
milan 2004 et que le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile n'étaient plus cette
année là que de 35 me contre 40 me l'an
2000 c'est bien la preuve qu'on peut
avoir une politique migratoire efficace
et je parlerai pas des autres thèmes
comme la lutte contre les mariages de
complaisance le durcissement du
regroupement familial la détection
systématique des faux diplômes la
progression sans précédent du nombre de
reconduites à la frontière qui sont
ahmed kamal actifs de cette période et
des prêts de 33000 sortie du territoire
en 2011 2002 plus qu'en 2019
ma question ma question aujourd'hui
porte sur le fait que nous apprenons par
la presse sans en passer par la
représentation nationale que vous avez
décidé de répartir un certain nombre
d'immigrés que considéré après les
évacuations de camps qui sont dans des
conditions indignes dans la région
parisienne dans des régions qui sont
considérés comme sous dotées moi
j'estime que pour reprendre le contrôle
de cette politique il faut une volonté
politique très forte et ferme et non une
politique de répartition alors monsieur
le ministre pourquoi choisissez-vous de
répartir sans en europe sans en parler à
la représentation nationale
ces personnes qui sont évacués des camps
indigne de la région parisienne
merci madame madame v rien merci
monsieur le président moi je voudrais
vous parler de la formation des
policiers qui se révèle toujours plus
courtes
alors qu'en fait leur rôle se
complexifie et donc c'est probablement
dommage le
de même il nous a été fait remarquer
qu'elles n'étaient pas des plots menthe
au niveau notamment de la formation
continue contrairement aux formations de
la gendarmerie
donc ce qui est préjudiciable pour le
travail que ces policiers peuvent
effectuer ensuite comme le font
d'ailleurs les gendarmes aujourd'hui et
enfin je voudrais vous parler moi aussi
d'un texte qui est un peu à côté mais
qui arrive avant la fin du mois qui est
la protection requis et le code pénal
des mineurs puisque effectivement ça
concerne essentiellement la justice mais
malgré tout le premier contact que les
mineurs délinquants auront ce sera à la
police ou à la gendarmerie
donc est-ce que policiers et gendarmes
seront formés je vous rappelle que le
garde des sceaux souhaite que cette
réforme soit applicable dès le 31 mars
prochain
et enfin vous j'adore les questions de
l'informatique est ce que le logiciel
qui permettra de sortir la bonne
convocation avec les bonnes références
de textes pour la première convocation
chez le juge pour
à voir comment ça s'appelle le le le
fait d'être coupable ou pas la
culpabilité ou pas est-ce que les
logiciels seront mises à jour dans les
temps et monsieur dur merci monsieur le
président je vais dire monsieur le
ministre l entame de cette question que
nous partageons certains des objectifs
du texte un continuum de sécurité et la
protection de ceux qui nous protège
évidemment peut-être plutôt que des
questions précises puisque nous sommes
encore dans la phase d'auditions et que
l'on aura l'occasion d'approfondir tout
ça en séance deux remarques
la première concerne ce qui nous a été
dit lors de l'audition de la conférence
des procureurs sur la chaîne de
compétences pour établir les saisies et
les procès verbaux la chaîne de
compétences municipales pour laquelle il
nourrissait des inquiétudes
on sait que les procès verbaux sont la
base des procédures la base des enquêtes
et que les risques d'une nullité
attachés à des procès verbaux qui serait
mal rédigée sont importants le doute sur
la capacité d'un chef de service de
pouvoir superviser travail de
fonctionnaires peu ou trop mal formés et
réel donc ce point d'un appareil est
important donc je pense que c'est un des
objectifs auxquels on doit on doit
s'attacher dans nos débats et est en
train d'arriver à rechercher avec nos
travaux deuxième sujet est évidemment
autour de l'article 24 alors je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de climat force
est de constater que le climat ne s'est
pas apaisée que coûte froid qu'on a
connus sur le pays n'a pas rafraîchi les
ardeurs de ceux qui s'opposent à ce
texte
on avait tout à l'heure une table ronde
et il faut remercier les rapporteurs de
journaliste je les relayer les
inquiétudes qu'on a qu'on a entendu cet
après-midi sur la capacité qu'ils auront
après la mise en oeuvre éventuelle de
cet article 24 à accéder à l'information
une des questions qui nous a été posée
c'est notamment la question du statut de
journaliste et de ce qui ne le sont pas
et qui contribuent pourtant la
fabrication de l'information droit
d'informer à être informé et puis j'ai
pris une question précise sur les drones
puisque la question était posée cet
après midi 2
la confidentialité ou du maintien du
secret des sources
avec l'utilisation des drones et qui
paraissait devoir être pouvoir être mis
en en cause par une utilisation abusive
des drones lors des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
merci monsieur dire à monsieur le
ministre mais aussi de répondre aux
questions relatives aux questions qui
ont été posées
merci monsieur le président alors la
question mon programme derby évidemment
le procureur de la république il est
essentiel dans ce dispositif puisque
c'est sous son autorité
que vont réagir les agents qui vont
constater des délits et pour les
policiers nationaux et pour les
gendarmes qui font des enquêtes
d'ailleurs c'est un point très important
je constate que des rapporteurs de ne
l'évoquent pas mais à l'assemblée
nationale s'est régulièrement groupe
l'est républicain
parfois ça cher ça chez certains maires
il ya une demande que les policiers
municipaux puissent faire exactement ce
que font les policiers nationaux par
exemple accéder à tous les fichiers par
exemple de pouvoir contraindre la
liberté de telle ou telle personne
parfois d attention j'ai bien compris
des lions au sénat et singulièrement jeu
je connais de sérieux à la fois du
ministre devrait celle du sénateur avait
mais j'aurais quand même dire que ça
voudrait dire comme conséquence mais
tout peut imaginer que les policiers
municipaux sont sous l'autorité
exclusive du procureur de la république
et que j'ai dit à plusieurs des mères
que j'ai pu rencontrer dire je n'ai pas
recruté et moi dans ma ville de
tourcoing des policiers municipaux pour
qu'ils ne soient que sous l'autorité du
procureur de la république
ou alors c'est une façon peut-être un
peu étonnant d'imaginer évidemment
l'intérêt commun mais je suis pas sûr
que ce soit la volonté première de tout
ce qu'ils demandaient ces dispositifs
puisque des procureurs à lui qu'est
celui qui donne à sa trempe de
possibilités d'actions ou qui permet qui
autorise enquête et qui permet à sa
tombe de privation de liberté comme
chacun de chacun de ces câbles c'est
donc là il s'agit bien évidemment d'un
procureur de la république ou d'une
pointure de la république qui amène sa
politique pénale commis longtemps les à
éviter par exemple de ce que prendra
comme dans la normale la possibilité que
lui et sa loi le programme devrait plus
pouvoir quelle drogue
quelle quantité comment on renseigne la
police municipale sera sous l'autorité
de ce que décidera
évidemment le procureur public qui
classera ou ne sera pas tel ou tel
constat donc évidemment le procureur
reste notre pierre angulaire
j'entends d'ailleurs souvent des choses
produire les policiers nationaux font
bon et se sent souvent sous l'autorité
d'un magistrat
je suis un un employeur mais pas
toujours le donneur d'ordres un chacun
de chacun le comprend et c'est très bien
ainsi puisque notre droit est fondé sur
cette action sur une question de madame
assassiné notamment sur les questions
qui relèvent des tâches indues je
comprends bien la rhétorique que kiki
vaut pas simplement par les forces de
sécurité mais qui fait du groupe
communiste et je respecte tout à fait
cette position idéologique de d'éviter
les délégations de service public les
dégagements vers d'autres de ce qu'il
fait l'action de la fonction publique
mais mais je peux pas tout à fait là la
suivre en revanche sur la conclusion
faite par le sociologue callac la cité
dont les jets pas retenu le nom puisque
si la conséquence la suppression de
poste vous m'expliquerez pourquoi nous
sommes vraiment concret le plus sous la
vème république des postes puisqu'on a
créé dix mille postes supplémentaires de
policiers de gendarmes rien une 2000
encore dans l'année 2021 alors que nous
allons vers des tâches indues et c'est
bien normal
je prends des exemples madame madame à
ça si aujourd'hui je ne comprends pas
pourquoi entreprise à d'ailleurs ce sont
des policiers qui quasi systématiquement
quasi systématiquement font les accueils
des commissariats le jour pour cela d
accueil et ensuite pour mettre en
contact
la personne qui se portait plainte koné
violences conjugales envie d'avoir de
l'information l'accueil c'est pas
forcément un policier en uniforme et
avec une arme qui doit le faire dans un
administratif peut tout à fait de serre
formés à l'accueil à l'accompagnement et
puis évidemment c'est pas elle prend les
pleins de cette personne 1 c'est bien
sûr un fonctionnaire de police
mais ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une tâche
ardue il s'agit pas de remplacer par
quelqu'un qui fait du privé mais par un
autre fonctionnaire qu'on appelle la
substitution par exemple je n'ai pas
toujours compris pourquoi dans
l'intégralité des cra c'est toujours des
forces de l'ordre qui le temps se fout
de la bagagerie
c'est quand vous allez dans un centre de
rétention administratif les affaires des
personnes qui sont au centre de
rétention ils sont mis dans une
bagagerie et ce sont des policiers
d'après sans frontières qui s'occupe de
cette base
galerie alors dans des conditions les
cra pourrait voir des gens très
dangereux pour imaginer que même les
gens qui sont non pas la surveillance du
kram et à côté du cra soit des policiers
mais enfin dans l'essentiel des sujets
que nous évoquons on prend tout à fait
imaginer délégué à quelqu'un d'autre
soit 207 bagagerie et le policier aux
frontières armes et le prix sans
frontières forme et il a peut-être
d'autres actions à faire que celui de
s'occuper de la bagagerie d'un certain
nombre de 2,2 cra sur la garde statique
d'un certain nombre de deux
comment dirais-je de fait par exemple à
des gens qui sont réanimation qui sont
des condamnés aux questions des
personnes qui sont en accusation et qui
ont des problèmes cardiaques selon une
crise cardiaque qui sont en réanimation
est ce que ce sont des policiers qui
doivent toujours garder à l'entrée alors
quand il s'agit de gens qui sont
soupçonnés d'être dans un grand
banditisme qui prévoit revengeance
évidemment mais lorsqu'il s'agit pas
manifestement de personnes qui relèvent
de cette catégorie on n'est pas obligé
de penser que ce sont bons on a des
conventions organisation pénitentiaire
aujourd'hui vous savez bien c'est les
policiers qui souvent quasiment tout le
temps amène soit dans les cra c'est à
limoges hier pour aller au cra de
bordeaux vos trois heures aller retour
un peu c'est ça comme du temps pris
policiers bon donc ce que l'on peut pas
imaginer que l'admiration pénitentiaire
ou d'autres personnes puissent occuper
de ces choses-là s'agit pas toujours de
le délégué à la sécurité privée même si
pour moi c'est pas un mauvais mot ça
peut être aussi que chaque fonctionnaire
puisse faire le travail pour lequel il a
été formé pour lequel il est le mieux
utilisé
donc il s'agit pas de quand on parle de
tâches indues madame la présidente
d'ivoire la privatisation à outrance et
il ya des agents de sécurité privés qui
par ailleurs pourrait faire un certain
nombre de tâches en tout cas je pense
que l'on devrait l'expérimenté même
quand elle évoque l'augmentation des
délinquances suite à l'article du figaro
dans dans les campagnes alors ces
augmentations des vacances dans les
campagnes elles relèvent de trois types
qui sont très intéressants dans la
délinquance pour voir quelle réponse on
peut apporter d'abord une délinquance
routière jeudi la représentation
nationale que les trois grands maux qui
touchent notre société les violences
conjugales et intrafamiliales qui sont
en augmentation et également dans les
territoires ruraux les délits routiers
je souhaiterais mois si le sénat le
président
de la commission pourrait nous aider de
voir comment on peut lutter contre ce
phénomène que toutes les demi heures et
toutes les 20 minutes en zone
gendarmerie
il ya des délits routiers il ya des
refus d'obtempérer des gens qui parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le bon permis de
conduire parce qu'ils n'ont pas déclaré
leur assurance parce que parfois ils ont
des stupéfiants ils ont sous l'emprise
d'alcool ou de stupéfiants prennent la
vie de gendarmes policiers ou d'autres
personnes évidemment parce qu'il refuse
de s'arrêter
ce sont une explosion continue des
délinquants c'est évidemment en zone
gendarmerie a plus de route qu'il y en a
en zone police il ya plus de contrôle
quant au lycée troisièmement les actes
commis contre ce qu'on pourrait appeler
le monde agricole par des introductions
dans les fermes le vol de carburant des
atteintes aux bestiaux enfin bref ça
tombe de deux sujets que vous connaissez
bien à ces augmentations traduisent une
forme de délinquance qu'il faut prendre
en compte est évidemment la création de
postes dans la gendarmerie nationale
leur façon aussi d'imaginer et leur
implantation territoriale compte une
replantation numérique compte beaucoup
également
on savait que les gendarmes ont
participé particulièrement avancés dans
leur présence territoriale grâce
notamment aux tablettes neohaler
géolocalisation et à leur intervention
et demain nous n'espérons laissez suer
intercommunaux les csu départementaux
qui permettront de donner dans les zones
rurales
même si les gendarmes ne font pas que de
la ruralité ils font aussi beaucoup
d'interventions dans les zones urbaines
il va permettre sans doute davo
d'accompagner ce que n'ont pas les
policiers c'est à dire souvent des
caméras d'une protection qui les aident
à intervenir ce qui est pas le cas vous
savez bien souvent des communes ne l'est
plus les plus rurales donc c'est un
travail très très très très important et
ses tâches indues je le redis permettent
aussi de pouvoir libérer un certain
nombre d'effectifs pour les remettre sur
le terrain en ont l'occasion d'en
reparler
alors madame boyer a évoqué des sujets
qui effectivement
rapport très lointain avec le texte mais
je voudrais pas là l'a frustré dans ma
réponse
bon je veux bien qu'elle compare alors
elle évoque le temps où nicolas sarkozy
d' ennemi de l'intérieur jeu
je voudrais faire remarquer que c'était
un temps sans doute important béni je me
dirais faveur pas beaucoup parce qu'à
l'époque j'étais étudiant donc je crois
que ce que d'abord j'étais parlementaire
avec elle après la défaite du président
sarkozy et quand elle a évoqué les vingt
ans d'augmentation massive des
migrations je pense qu'elle lesquels
évoqué aussi sa propre autocritique que
je les imagine bien volontiers mais je
le dire à madame boyer qu'on peut pas
comparer les choses comme celle ci
d'abord madame boyer vous aurez constaté
que vous comparez des chiffres dans des
moments où les régimes notamment du
maghreb et de l'afrique était dans une
stabilité politique un peu différente en
libye en tunisie au maroc en turquie au
théâtre syrien le pirate irakien n'est
pas tout à fait dans les mêmes
prédispositions que m6 a rappelé pas que
l'action du président sarkozy je les
doux et je la loue soit des questions de
sécurité étaient tout à fait comparable
aka politiques migratoires que nous
connaissons ce sinon ça veut dire que le
bilan du président de la république que
vous semblez attaqué je devrais être
attaqués aussi par la chancelière merkel
puisqu'il suffit de constater les
chiffres des migrations en allemagne ils
sont bien plus bien plus important nous
aimons je pense que madame madame
voiliers devraient se méfier des
chiffres puisque quand on fera le bilan
de l'année 2020 elle va quand la moins
40 % de titres donnés en l'année 2020
qu'elle verra que sur 135 mille
demandeurs d'asile seul un quart ont des
titres d'asile et que notre problème
n'est pas tant le nombre de personnes
qui viennent sur le territoire national
que notre difficulté à les reconduire
dans leur pays qui est un vrai sujet
comment prendre un cutter comme les
autres pays il faut avouer qu'en 2020
comme les plus de vols réguliers vers
les pays du maghreb notamment mais aussi
vers des pays lointains qui sont un
théâtre de guerre je l' ai déjà dit
syrie ou irak voir dans des pays dans
lesquels nos relations diplomatiques
sont plus que compliquée pour obtenir
des laissez-passer compris l'air cheap
pakistan par exemple puisque sa marque
et que les relations entre nos
dirigeants sont pas simple parce que par
ailleurs le président a répliqué
courageux ceci explique sans doute cela
je constaterai d'ailleurs madame la
députée que si on regarde le chiffre des
naturalisations
elle verra qu'il 20% de plus de
naturalisation entre 2007 et 2012 peut
maintenant donc je crois qu'il faut
faire attention aux comparaisons
elles ne sont pas toujours elles sont
pas toujours raison et je m'en voudrais
de ne pas lui avoir répondu même six
débats migratoire je comprends tout à
fait est un débat qui n'est pas un débat
à caricaturer qui mérite une vraie
discussion est sans doute une
amélioration de l'action publique et
singulièrement dans la reconduite à la
frontière puisque dans le contrôle des
frontières
il n'y a jamais eu autant de policiers
de gendarmes à nos frontières et
d'ailleurs je le dis à madame boyer
c'est le président de la république et
avant lui le président hollande qui
allons fermer grâce au traité que
prévoit notamment les accords de
schengen même si je pense
personnellement qu'il faut revoir ses
accords l'occasion de le faire le
président rapplique encourager l'union
pérenne en europe à ne le faire de
rétablir nos frontières ce qui n'était
pas le cas dans les années le début des
années 2000 puisque c'était un autre
moment et personne ne peut faire ce
procès ni à monsieur jose par monsieur
chirac mais monsieur sarkozy à monsieur
fillon
puisque c'étaient des moments climatique
et géopolitique très très différents le
le sujet évoqué sur la formation est
tout à fait essentiel je le comprends
mille fois j'ai moi même évoqué ait eu
des erreurs de réduire les formations
ont valu à la formation initiale mais je
dois avouer que le parlement doit
si comprendre qu'on peut pas à la fois
demander plus effectif misé de
l'intérieur et plus longtemps de
formation et à bout d'un moment ça
défile se connecte pas tout à fait donc
si on fait plus de formation initiale
quand on recrute des policiers il faut
accepter qu'ils viennent moins vite dans
les commissariats donc on a on a parfois
un débat c'est sans doute ce qui a
poussé mes prédécesseurs a raccourci
dans cette formation initiale et je
pense que c'était une erreur je les dis
et puis à la formation continue la
formation continue théorique puis la
commission formation continue pratique à
avoir théoriquement ils ont pas assez
vous avez raison d'heures de formation
les policiers ni juridique ni physique
ni technique vous avez bien raison et
même quand ils en ont je prends
l'exemple du commissariat de limoges 50
heures de formation annuelle ils ont
n'ont fait qu'une dizaine parce qu'il
n'y a pas le temps ce qui sont hyper
mobiliser parce que les manifestations
dans grand public la sécurité publique a
fait l'ordre public parce qu'on n'a pas
réglé le problème toujours des horaires
dans la police nationale
parce qu'à des et que tout ce qui prend
comme parfois pour les crs qu on prend
sur la formation et c'est pas bien parce
que du coup on évite aux policiers
d'abord dans un bon cycle de travail
comme tout salarié comme tout
travailleur quel droit à sa formation et
on ne le lui permet pas d'être à jour si
j'ose dire et c'est leur responsabilité
de l'état employeur c'est à dire moi et
donc on va changer effectivement les
choses et puis après il ya les
formations qui relève notamment des tirs
administratif il doit faire trois tirs
par l'administratif par an vous
constaterez qu'ils sont quasiment tous
concentrés c'est une caricature mais au
mois de décembre par manque de stand de
tir
on peut imaginer les choses on veut
travailler que les polices municipales
pour faire des stands de tir comme on
peut l'imaginer les stands de tir mobile
mais quand il ya un problème avec un
policier que fait l'igpn rien ne sait
rien de ces défaites et trois tirs et
nous devons à nos policiers
je crois le chiffre que j'avais retenu
c'est plus de 60% des policiers selon
qui des entretiens ministre at-il dans
l'année donc il ya améliorer les durées
de formation initiale et continue mais
déjà appliquer ce qu'on sait faire et ça
demande un gros travail de ressources
humaines ce que j'ai demandé au
directeur général de la police nationale
les gendarmes comptent un système certes
différents mais enfin qui mérite quand
même d'être améliorée revue le directeur
général de la gendarmerie y travaillent
et notamment dans la coordination de nos
forces entre police et gendarmerie si je
prends le maintien de l'ordre
le travail des crs et des gendarmes
mobiles sur le terrain
complémentaire il faut qu'ils
travaillent plus de temps ensemble à se
former ensemble pour avoir des réflexes
et mieux se connaître les uns des uns
les autres mais je ne peux que souscrire
à votre votre votre propos sur le code
pénal et la façon dont le garde des
sceaux imagine des prochains textes de
lois bien évidemment il ya des policiers
d'art spécifiques
vous savez bien dans leurs fonctions et
dans leur métier et ils font un travail
très courageux d'ailleurs ce qui
concerne les mineurs ils ne voient pas
ils vont à la fois beaucoup d'humanité
et beaucoup de difficulté bien sûr à
traiter cette forme de délinquance qui
est en grandissante malheureusement est
donc évidemment nous travaillons plus
garde des sceaux pour à la fois former
aux nouveaux outils juridiques et qu'ils
seront conformes aux volonté du
législateur sur le logiciel
alors je sais de le magistrat seul qui
décide de la culpabilité ce n'est pas et
ce ne sera pas j'espère les logiciels de
la police parlait de la convocation est
générée par je le disais bien volontiers
pour que chacun ne l'entendent mais
j'avais bien compris comme ça je pense
que c'est donc parler d'un logiciel
magistrats les bêtes cassiopée si c'est
le cas je crois que maintenant de deux
parce que malgré tout le fait de venir
devant le juge la convocation va être
donné par la police avant d'aller après
le juge décidera ou pas de la
culpabilité mais c'est bien la police
qui va lui donner sa convocation mais
que la police lui donne c'est une chose
mais je vois que le logiciel vient de la
magistrature puisque d'accord c'est sur
cattiaux peut aussi qu'ils ont je crois
que c'est sûr cassiopée en revanche ne
veut pas dire que la police nationale la
gendarmerie de pamiers leurs process de
logiciels notamment d' enquêtes pénales
et nous y travaillons alors il ya deux
expérimentations dont j'encourage la
votre commission a peut-être aller voir
à amiens et à blois sur la procédure
pénale numérique qui le rapprochement
des deux ce qui évite beaucoup de
doublons et ce qui est très intéressant
qu'on va généraliser avec le garde des
sceaux à la fin de ces expérimentations
et de manière générale les doubles
écrans comme je lé fais la dgesip quand
je suis arrivé au ministère des comptes
publics
alors qu'on ne mérite il faut accepter
les doubles écrans pour les pour les
agents désinforme d utilisation de
logiciels de légende artificielle ou de
dicter plus efficace un bref il ya un
certain nombre de sujets voilà monsieur
de tels péages y m'évoque logiciels de
rédaction de procédure le rhdp qui est
en cours de réforme
ça vous saurez tout sur les logiciels
il est prêt à vous en parlait d'ailleurs
toute une soirée si vous l'invitez
monsieur le président vous dire
également que je partage à la question
des pv est mal rédigée mais je crois que
j'ai répondu le rapporteur daubresse et
encore une fois je voudrais pas qu'on
dise que ce sont les policiers
municipaux
même s'il ya un chef de service de la
police nationale gendarmerie doivent
aussi faire des efforts donc un très
gros travail de pgi notamment le
ministre intérieur que je suis dans la
police nationale à la fois manque de pj
sur le terrain et à 3000 au pgi qui sont
pas obligés certes ils sont au régime
qualification pj mais ils ont eu leur
qualification et ce en partie dans les
services qui ne sont pas dédiés aux
logiciels
quand j'ai mis fin aux primes des hauts
pj qui ne sont pas au pgi et réessayer
de améliorer les primes de ceux qui
prennent le risque ou qui font le
travail parfois fastidieux d'être au pgi
enfin bref je construirai de l'euro
structurellement ce problème c'est un
métier de fête officielle judiciaire qui
garantit le droit à tout le monde et qui
garantit évidemment la procédure et je
crois que c'est les procureurs ont
raison de vous alerter sur ce point sur
l'article 24 je comprends votre
intervention je vous comprendrait que je
pense avoir évoqué le sujet que quelle
que soit la rédaction ce qui intéresse
mise l'intérieur c'est qu'on puisse
continuer à protéger
je sais que c'est le cas de tout le
monde les policiers les gendarmes et que
le temps de la navette parlementaire
n'aura jamais été aussi bénéfique sans
doute à une disposition d'un texte de
loi
je le partage tout à fait et tant que le
but est atteint et que tout le monde
soit rassuré évidemment
le gouvernement ne pourra qu'y être
favorable merci monsieur le ministre
écoutez nous arrivons au terme de cette
audition je veux pas revenir sur les
points qui ont été évoqués bien
évidemment mais sur celui de l'article
24 puisque ça fait l'objet de beaucoup
de discussions la commission les
rapporteurs ne font en et proposeront
des propositions à la commission et nous
verrons dans la rédaction qui sera
proposé à remplir la première mission
qui essaient de protéger les policiers
n'y a aucun doute là dessus
soit ils ont totalement assuré une
veillerons aussi est ce que les choses
soient parfaitement rédigé pour qu'elle
ne pose aucune difficulté à personne car
notre intérêt c'est notre intérêt envers
le collectif c'était évidemment que les
choses se passent bien et que les
policiers qui exercent leurs fonctions
soit protégé dans l'exercice de leurs
missions
[Musique]